ELON MUSK'S TWITTER JUST
ANNOUNCING MAJOR NEW POLICIES
THAT COULD HAVE A MAJOR IMPACT
ON WHAT YOU TWEET.
TWITTER IS FORBIDDING USERS
FROM PROMOTING OTHER SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS, THAT MEANS
YOUR TWITTER ACCOUNT COULD BE
SUSPENDED FOR ASKING PEOPLE TO
FOLLOW YOU ON ANOTHER SITE.
THAT BAN INCLUDES FACEBOOK,
INSTAGRAM AND --
.
I AM JOINED NOW BY A BUSINESS
INSIDER COLUMNIST IT LINETTE
LOPEZ WHO HAS COVERED TWITTER
--
SHE WAS AMONG THE JOURNALISTS
WHO WERE SUSPENDED BY TWITTER
THIS PAST WEEK.
LYNETTE, I WANT TO HEAR YOUR
STORY AND MORE ABOUT IT IN JUST
A FEW MOMENTS BUT FIRST I WANT
TO GET YOUR REACTION TO THIS
NEW POLICY.
I SHOULD NOTE MY OWN ACCOUNT
WAS LOCKED OVERNIGHT BY
TWITTER.
ONE OF MY TWEETS WAS FOUND TO
HAVE VIOLATED TWITTER'S NEW
RULE ABOUT PROMOTING OTHER
SITES.
I HAD SAID YOU CAN FIND ME ON
POST AND MASTODON AND I WOKE UP
THIS MORNING AND MY ACCOUNT WAS
LOCKED.
I AM STILL TRYING TO SORTED
OUT.
BUT, LYNETTE, THIS ALL FEELS
VERY ARBITRARY AND LITTLE
FRENETIC.
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT PEOPLE
REALLY NEED TO UNDERSTAND ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN TWITTER
NOW IS THAT IT IS BEING RUN BY
ELON'S FEELINGS AND NOT BY ANY
THOUGHT ABOUT THE BUSINESS
MODEL, OR, IF YOU REALLY THINK
ABOUT TWITTER, THE POWER --
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO GENERATE
CONTENT.
WE DO IT FOR FREE YOU KNOW.
WE ARE THE ONES WHO MAKE THE
SITE INTERESTING TO GO TO.
ELON HAS JUST BEEN KICKING OFF
POWER USER, JOURNALISTS, WHO
ARE ADDICTED TO THIS SITE.
RIGHT AND LEFT.
AND THAT IS NOT GREAT FOR
TWITTER AS BUSINESS.
SO YOU HAVE TO WONDER, WHAT IS
HE THINKING?
AND, MY EXPERIENCE, WHICH WITH
ELON GOES BACK TO 2018 WHEN I
INVESTIGATED THE COMPANY FOR A
FEW YEARS, TESLA, HE DOES A LOT
OF THAT EMOTIONAL
DECISION-MAKING AND NOW IT IS
ALMOST AS IF HIS IT IS SPILLING
OUT ALL OVER THE INTERNET AND
ON TWITTER.
>> IT SURE SEEMS THAT WAY.
AND LANETT LIONEL MESSI YOUR
ACCOUNT WAS SUSPENDED AND HAS
NOT BEEN --
AND WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM
TWITTER?
>> I HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING
FROM TWITTER.
IT IS FUNNY THAT ELON HAS THIS
NEW POLICY AGAINST PUTTING UP
LINKS OR REFERRING TO OTHER
SOCIAL MEDIA SITES BECAUSE WHEN
HE FIRST STARTED A TWITTER
CAMPAIGN AGAINST ME IN 2018, HE
WAS TWEETING OUT PICTURES FROM
MY PACE BOOK PROFILE TO SHARE
WITH ALL OF HIS FANS ON THE
INTERNET.
SO, I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S
UPSET ELON, I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT UPSET TWITTER I
DID POST DOCUMENTS FROM A COURT
CASE ELON FILED AGAINST ONE OF
MY SUITS, MY SOURCES BACK IN
2019 I THINK.
SO, THERE MIGHT BE OLD INFO, I
DON'T THINK'S ADDRESS WAS ON
ANYTHING.
SO, I REALLY DON'T KNOW YET.
MA